hey guys in case you missed it we
started a new series on DM men's
lifestyle this is a series where it's
familyfriendly content where I just show
you what's going on in my life being a
true reborn Christian where I do daily
things I share a little bit of things
that I do at work with Nikita my awesome
wife here friends family people at work
and also what I love to do like fishing
and going outdoors and so expect to see
some great content in this day and
nature we live in where entertainment is
getting darker and darker I want to ask
you you please join me with your family
watch it it's on men's lifestyle it's on
one of the playlists called dlm
lifestyle we are on episode 2 right now
and this last uh weekend I went out with
the dlm team only men Donnie and jock we
went to pray spend time in God's word
and also do some fishing check it out
don't miss it love you guys bye